l'expression avoir une vie de chien vous
connaissez et ben moi j'avais la pire
qui soit
et puis si cela monsieur moins la même
couleur de poils je dis pas de chien et
quand je dis non c'est non tu as le plus
habile il est clair il est clair et
c'est mon nom là orange jeux se sont
déroulés dans une crotte l'usr leur
manière de faire des promenades
si la bullshit
vous avez dit que voulait pas prendre de
chiens tout le monde tous ces [ __ ]
trudeau chatel avait dit que vous vous
mariez pas vivant ok on est parti sur de
mauvaises bases et je vais me mettre
dans la poche
aux jeunes il s'en amuse pas sa
participation s'est pas passé ça aurait
peut-être de laisser gagner il va
diminuer
oui qu'est-ce qui se passe il faut pas
que tu as rêvé des bois mais non bien
sûr que non
voilà ça c'est de la promenade
est ce que tu nous a emmenés je vous
présente caroline et moi une ville
géniale je suis garde de chiens à elle à
toi ça va mal elle m'avait pas tu
travaille je travaille je suis un homme
comme les autres
vous allez pas divorcer au arrête avec
ça coûte pourquoi divorceraient tout va
bien concept avéré mois le cochon
vraiment un problème avec les promenades
dans cette famille alors que si vous
venez danser
attention c'est pas comme ça qu'on tient
un chien et c'est moi ça tu m'a
drôlement bien réussi j'ai la taille
aussi fier aïe voilà c'est la gaffe
ouais c'est encore mon nom là votre fils
est votre chien m'ont agressé dans
l'escalier annonçant la peau de chien je
leur dis pas tiens la maison et j'ai dû
céder